it's me lad hundred assalamualaikum
greetings of peace to everybody how are
you you come to get some food for the so
you can replete with everything else but
it's not satisfying the soul money can't
buy that happiness it won't bring you
peace not even a 6-pack of peace you
can't buy it
this madad hamdulillah Salam alaikum
greetings of peace to everybody all over
the globe thank you for tuning in to
another episode on the Deen show our
next guest was an inspiring aspiring
Baptist minister from Texas and he's
here on the Deen show to share his story
on why he came to this beautiful Deen
his way of life that brought him peace
happiness and contentment and he
realized that you know what I need to be
on the way of life that's pleasing to
the crater before I meet the crater and
he's here to share his story with us
here on the Deen show we'll be right
back this is the Deen the Bijou
this is the pain you know this is the
thesis the teacher
this is the theme show this is the
things is the theme this is the theme
this is the view this is I greet you
with the greetings of Jesus now before I
do that you already know where that is
what is that Salam peace beef where
people who want peace isn't it true I
mean now what would it what did you
think before it look time is short so I
just like to just get in it so tell us
before you became one who submitted to
the will of God a Muslim you were spying
Baptist minister what would you know
about Islam before well nothing nothing
did you believe that Muslims were like
terrorists Arabs you know they were
right in the desert on camels and no my
story begins back in 1989 when I was
actually in college and I was not
studying to be a minister but I decided
my senior year that I wanted to become a
Baptist minister so I decided to finish
my degree and my senior year for my
entertainment i drugged all of my
colleagues and friends and everybody I
knew into a religious conversation to
help me prepare for seminary as a
Baptist I was going to go to a Baptist
Seminary and my senior year in college
inviting people to talk about religion
if you haven't done this on a college
campus
I would highly recommend you do it just
for the entertainment value if nothing
else it's hard to find any two people
who agreed on anything and so as I'm
talking to people about religion I am
introduced to people who are Muslim I
became friends with somebody who is a
Muslim I didn't know the first thing
about Islam but after our introduction
and our friendship I drug him into a
religious conversation and it didn't
take me long to consider my friend a
confused Christian I knew nothing about
Islam but from what he was sharing with
me we had a very similar faith except he
was confused about Jesus so before we
get tell us so but why did you get into
this field why did you want to become a
Baptist minister why specifically that
area well I was
Christiaan my family was Christian and
as I went to school I actually grew up
in a very conservative family where I
didn't have a lot of what I thought was
freedom so when I got to college I I I
cut loose and I enjoyed myself for the
first second third year and after a
while I started to think this is not who
I am this is not how I was brought up
this is not me so I had an epiphany that
I wanted to become a Baptist minister
and get back to where I belong back to
the faith so this is what encouraged me
to decide to become a Baptist minister
now you have what would he have
Lutheran's you have nondenominational
how many actually thousands or hundreds
of denominations sects are there and how
did you come to this one because of your
family yeah my family I grew up Baptist
so that was it just your continuing -
traditionally my mom loved me my dad
loved me they wouldn't lie had to be
right
what do Baptists actually believe what
do they actually believe yeah did you
believe that Jesus was Lord Savior he
was God Almighty as a Baptist you leavin
a verse called John 3:16 that for God so
loved the world that He gave His only
begotten Son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life so God sent not his son
into the world to condemn the world but
that the world through him might be
saved so Jesus was my savior as a
Baptist so Baptist believed that you
just have to have faith is that right
you just have to have faith that Jesus
died for your sins and you're going to
heaven right they believe that salvation
is based on grace that nobody can earn
salvation and that if you accept the
atonement of Jesus the payment of sins
the atonement then that's how you attain
salvation okay so now you meet this
Muslim what happens next well I met the
Muslim and we talked about religion
uh-huh and after he explained a little
bit about Islam I considered him a
confused Christian that was my summary
of what I had shared with me so we
continue to talk and as we talked about
religious or religion in general every
time we brought up a topic he wasn't
necessarily practicing he wasn't in the
he wasn't trying to convert me at all we
met in a bar
so we didn't meet in like a religious
environment yeah so he wasn't even
practically to you hopeful Islam is he
he would then every time we had this
conversation he loved to talk religion
he loved the dark politics so he was not
shy to talk
he just wasn't practicing yeah and so
after we'd have a conversation the next
time we met he would bring me a book a
pamphlet a brochure something on that
topic but a religious comparative
dialogue between a Muslim and a
Christian so I would get this
information and as I would be presented
with this comparative religion dialogue
between me and my friend I start to hear
some of the the dialogue this that
Muslims and Christians have had forever
this interfaith dialogue what are the
differences what are the similarities in
Islam I was introduced to one of the
probably renowned scholars a gentleman
named Amida Dodd who passed away he's
not been met him no I read all this book
he actually brought me one book at a
time for mom and dad because it it tied
into our conversations I started getting
information from mama didn't I get
information from Jamal baduy Gary Miller
all the places religious dialogue
started to to come alive and I'm taking
it upon myself to convert my new Muslim
friend to Christianity and I'm learning
about Islam in the process and I'm
continuing to have religious
conversations with everybody around me
just for my entertainment basically drag
them into the conversation and what I'm
finding out is that everybody has a
different opinion about religion or
whatever it is they believe why they
believe it and what's holding them to it
and it started to frustrate me like how
do you share with everybody who's
different a religion when nobody here
you know somebody has an emotional
attachment somebody had an experience
somebody was driving a car so and it's
like how do you how am I going to do
Dawa as a Christian right and I
it occurred to me through the
conversation I had with my friends that
the best way to do now would be to
convince other people of how authentic
and persuasive the Bible is you can rely
on the Bible you can trust the Bible you
can use the Bible as your authority so I
decided that my Dawa as a Christian
would be to use the Bible to persuade
other people of Christianity instead of
an emotional connection instead of an
argument so because I wanted to go that
route I decided to to learn more about
the history of the Bible so that I could
convince others of its authority do I
mean no keep going okay so as I did that
I myself had to learn more about the
Bible I was convinced the Bible was true
again my mom loved me she wouldn't lie
this has to be right everybody I knew
was Christian so it was just me that
needed to know how to understand the
Bible better to present it as I started
to study the Bible and what's called the
historicity of the Bible
I started to learn more about the book
that I believed in the more I learned
about the book I believed in the more
confused I became I started to learn
things that I didn't learn in Sunday
school things I didn't hear in church
service things that it was never told to
me as a Christian give us an example
well I started to learn how we got the
Bible and the Bible is a collection of
books that have come together over time
and I was shocked to find out that the
books that are now in the Bible
specifically the King James Version of
the Bible
just in case there's different versions
that we don't know who the authors are
there are people today you pick up a
Bible the author is unknown we pick up
books of the Bible we find that the Old
Testament the copies we have of the Old
Testament the oldest version of the Old
Testament is newer than the oldest
versions of the New Testament and we
find that these there were councils and
votes taken on which book should be in
which should be out and that when you
look for the history of this book you
start to say it's more concerning than
persuasive and the more I learned about
the his
three of the Bible the more challenging
my own conviction became and I started
to learn and really thought I have a bad
habit and that is if something's worth
doing it's worth overdoing
so I have this one speed you know full
speed ahead
yeah so I immersed myself in this my
senior year and talking to people about
religion and trying to convince them
about the authority of the Bible and as
I'm learning more about the Bible and I
learned about the New Testament and
learn more about Jesus and he spoke
Aramaic and nothing's can nothing's been
preserved in his original tongue
nothing's in Hebrew the closest dialect
that the Jews spoke and preserved all
their religion in so I started to get
more and more frustrated with the
authority of the Bible then I started
reading more about comparative religious
dialogue and these authors like a MIDI
dad or somebody who is trying to show
that maybe there's a better authority
than the Bible was challenging the
Bible's is the Bible God's Word is this
you know are authentic is this accurate
as I'm struggling with that to try to to
actually command it where I can persuade
somebody else I'm introduced to more
ideas one of the ideas I had no idea
that even existed is that Muslims think
that Mohammed is mentioned in the Bible
and I said no I've been to school I've
grown up in this religion we don't talk
about Mohammed he's not in the book he's
not in the Old Testament he's not in the
New Testament I'm pretty sure this is
where you've gone off base but I asked
people to share with me what verses they
feel applying to the Prophet Mohammed
and there's a plethora there's lots of
verses that people say this is this is
the Prophet Muhammad in the Bible and
you go read the verse and it may not say
the Prophet by name but it mentions
somebody's going to do something at a
certain time in a certain way and as I
read these verses I'm thinking whatever
you want to interpret anybody can came
up with any conclusion they want but for
me I wanted to know what the Christian
would say to the Muslim in response so I
got the best answers I could to explain
each verse and as I heard the argument
of this is the Prophet Muhammad here's
his life here's his story here's where
he's coming from here
what he's going to do here's how he's
going to do it here's what he's going to
say all of this started to persuade me
that my book that I believed in was
actually ordering me to follow this
person that I didn't even recognize and
that only did it ordered me to follow
him it was so specific as to what and
who and how and every way that this
person was the person who he claimed to
be Mohamed and that Christians and Jews
were told to follow once he came so to
make a long story short I actually the
time I graduated I had learned enough
about the history of the Bible I could
run a comparative religious study of
Muhammad in the Bible is the Bible God's
Word
I had challenged the authority of the
Quran and tried to tear it apart because
once I saw the similarities I saw the
problems I was having with the Bible and
I tried to do to discredit the Quran in
the same way I was actually discrediting
myself and I found that the Quran ended
up being everything I wanted
Christianity to be as far as authority
and authenticity so by the time I
graduated I embraced Islam instead of
going to seminary this is a very
intriguing story my ears are glued I'm
sure yours are all so don't go anywhere
because we've got a lot more to talk
about with Camille Leakes here on the
Deen show we'll be right back you think
these things are going to bring you
happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain think you're happy you're
kidding yourself is really awesome what
we are offering in Islam what we have
found in Islam for ourselves is a means
by which our hearts are in peace they're
at rest they're not discontent we are
pleased with what we have
[Music]
back here with Khaleel Meeks aspiring
baptist minister now you're a Muslim and
at that time was it was it something
that at that time you're getting
confused obviously now all these things
that you're believing for your whole
life you believed in your whole life and
now here comes all this new information
were you scared what were some of the
things that were going through your mind
did you want to shut it off did you just
want to or was it was it it was it
something that was motivating you more
did you go back to some of your friends
Christian some of the higher-ups and did
they tell you look this is from the
devil leave it alone
to talk to us about this well as I was
doing my research and it basically a
boil back down to the same question that
I posed beginning of my Muslim friend
instead of him being a confused
Christian maybe I was a confused Muslim
and my my search at that point came down
to is Jesus God or not that was it your
mind is he Goddard if he's God then I'm
a Christian if he's not I'm almost
simple that was it and so as I wanted to
focus on that issue what I started to
see is Jesus speaking to me from the
Bible in his own words not what I heard
from the the minister not what I heard
in Sunday school not the theology I
wanted Jesus to tell me who he is where
I came what he did so I could see if
Jesus is telling me he's God or if he
says something different and when I
start looking at Jesus and what he said
in the Bible he said the father is
greater than I I have mine own self do
nothing why call us me good there's none
good but the father our Father who art
in heaven even on the cross he says my
God my God why has Al forsaken so I
start to hear Jesus telling me he's not
God I start to see Jesus saying that I
am NOT what you're hearing from others
are their interpretation of what Jesus
said and so when I studied even more and
I really wanted to know I mean that you
take soul-searching when you when you
base your faith on something
and that foundation is challenged I'm
not one to run from it I was just one
too to go more into it so I really
wanted to know if I was right or if
Islam was right and hearing the the
concept of tawheed of Islam that God is
one that like you say we we worship the
Creator not the creation you can touch
it taste it see it feel it it's less
than divine somehow it is it's dependent
on something else so Islam was simple it
was straightforward it was direct it
said that Jesus was a prophet he spoke
the truth everything he said is true
he said the father is greater than I I
didn't do this so follow what I say and
worship God versus did he come with a
with a mission to atone for sin and this
vicarious atonement and is this issue of
sin so profound that we have to have
this mechanism the salvation for us to
enter Heaven and from every angle I
could approach it from logic from
emotion from history from talking to
everybody I could surround myself with
everything that I kept hearing kept
pointing me towards Jesus is not God
there is one God there's a heaven hell a
day of judgment and I need to be ready
for that what about the people to say
well we know that he's not God he's the
son of he's the begotten Son of God and
no one comes to the Father except
through me they quote this what he what
he had he respond to this if words have
meaning Christianity's theology cannot
hold to start with divine nature denies
sonship you can't be a divine son you
can be a son and you can't be divine or
you can be God so to be the son of God
is a contradiction as you move forward
in this concept where Jesus said
something
and that how do you interpret what he
says right I am my father are one it can
be interpreted a million ways but he
give you the one in purpose he could be
one and the same person it could mean
lots of things but when you asked Jesus
who are you
are you Christ the Son of God even that
title he refused to accept he said no
until no man such a thing
others continue to apply it but he
didn't say so these these these verses
that people say that Jesus claimed to be
God have no bearing on the fact that he
was saying I am equal to God John 1:1 in
the beginning was the word and where the
Word was with God and the word became
flesh you'll hear this thrown out as
soon as you say he's not God this will
be all spat in your face what you guys
about that you could answer all of them
with the same force of if what they if I
give you the argument of anything that
Jesus said you know God said I am and
Jesus said well before Abraham was I am
you know that were to us so that
therefore he's God without going into
the the Linguistics and what could be
said and what wasn't it it's a
straightforward argument that when Jesus
said the father is greater than I write
I of mine own self do nothing why call
us me good there's none good but the
father those verses would be equally
challenging for any human being to say
well they have this esoteric meaning
they have this mean that so this show
isn't long enough for me to explain the
real meaning of what they have but I'm
just saying in a very simple manner that
Jesus was very clear as to who he was
why he came and what he did and in my
opinion he ordered Muslims to follow
Muhammad I'll give you this one verse
give us in John sixteenth chapter of
John in the Bible I'll use the King
James Version Jesus is speaking to his
disciples about things to come and he
said nevertheless I tell you the truth
it's expedient for me Jesus to go for if
I do not go the comforter will not come
but if I go I will send him unto you and
he and then a fever
and he the Spirit of Truth will not
speak of himself but what he hears he
shall speak and he shall guide you unto
all truth
now I have a Muslim audience in front of
me right now
if I ask you what did Jesus mean in that
verse who would he be referring to
Mohammed if I asked a Christian they
wouldn't bat an eye they would say that
is the comforter the Holy Ghost right so
he's saying the Holy Ghost is coming
this Trinity God the Father the Son the
Holy Ghost these three and one there's
not three but they're the same so I'll
tell the Christian well let's read the
verse with clarity so that we're clear
on your position right Jesus is God God
the Father is God and the Holy Ghost is
God if we read the verse with just
simplicity we say God said to the Jews
he said it's expedient for God to go for
if God does not go God will not come but
if God goes God will send God unto you
then later says and God the Spirit of
Truth will not speak of God's self but
what God hears God shall speak and God
shall guide you into all truth I don't
have to explain that yeah and when you
look at the Bible and you take out this
this gymnastics of what words mean or
what they can't mean and how they mean
things it becomes clear what it's
telling you to do it's saying there's
one God there's a heaven there's a hell
there's a day of judgment there's a
person who's coming after Jesus who's
going to do these things from where he's
going to come the city the people the
tribe the things he's going to do you
can't mistake it you would have to have
to ignore it bury it run from it as to
accept it it's got to be lucid it's got
to be clear it can't be now esoteric as
you said and let's just you know it's
confusion mental gymnastics to make it
work God's message got to be clear you
can take him for what it says and it
tells you to be a Muslim one who is
submitted to the will of God we'll be
right back with more here on the Deen
show all of the prophets would have been
because this essential message was the
same submission
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the Pope on Sunday morning
and preach a sermon that I knew was
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity did you say that you're not
believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of his name you can not be a
Muslim is attending our faith to believe
in and love Jesus Christ comes to you
the truth and the attribute of the one
who created you that he's one and alone
running this universe that he doesn't
become born he doesn't die he doesn't
eat and go to the bathroom
this is not God problem cheers yeah it's
this doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshiping Jesus recorded
in the gospel despite all of the other
issues about the gospel you put those
aside to say it's mentioned there that
Jesus works from hunger back here on the
Deen show what is aspiring Baptist
minister you were working hard you went
through life chasing your desires you
let loose as you said and then you
wanted to be a man of God you obviously
believed in God you met a Muslim one who
submitted to the will of God a Muslim is
simply one who was like Jesus Jesus was
a Muslim is that true or not yes Moses
was a Muslim amen amen
because a Muslim is one who submits to
the will of God so now that tell us you
have obviously spoke to some professors
at seminary school have you people
who've attended graduated tell us you
know when when they come across people
such as Bible scholars such as bar Aaron
we've heard of him right and other
scholars who tell us that we don't have
a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy of
anything original from the Bible right
is that true
you know what arguments and why don't
people like as yourself obviously you
were searching for God for the truth you
know I asked you was it scary was it you
know intimidating because societal
pressures maybe your family I was
talking to one person on the street the
other day and they say oh it makes sense
my grandmother would kill me if I became
a Muslim you know so how did your
parents accept this and how do people
you know in those higher positions do
they know they know that we don't have
the original text
Matthew didn't write Matthew Luke these
were you know the they're anonymous
books what excuse do people give I mean
do you ever look someone is a come on
man
I've been here we'd kidding I'm no I I
say that when you get a little
comfortable with someone you know what
I'm saying I'm very comfortable I I
don't have a problem talking about it
but what what I find is that there are
apologetics for everything and if you
hold a position and you want to defend
it you will see things the way you want
to see them I don't think that the most
eloquent argument or the most profound
statement or the most direct approach to
convincing somebody ever works I've
argued with people until I'm blue in the
face I invite Theological Seminary
students to my house to practice before
they go so that they get ready for Islam
so they'll come over and they don't buy
anything that I say applies to Mohammed
they have apologized for everything
they're convinced there's not one heir
they're convinced that this Bible is
perfect and whole and complete they've
heard what I've said they've seen what
I've said they have their position it's
my opinion after spending the last 21 22
years that trying to talk somebody into
Islam is a bad idea that Muslims have a
much more powerful way to express their
faith and to talk to people and that is
just shut up and be a Muslim every time
I have these debates and I like them I
enjoy them to me it's a it's a fun thing
to have somebody who knows what they're
talking about challenge my faith back
and forth but I've never seen that
effective or somebody do you know like
you said okay buddy now tell me are you
with me because they get more dogmatic
more defensive more distance even though
we're still in the same room but if I
say excuse me I need a minute
I have to go pray because it's just
about time to run so I go pray and I
come back they haven't heard a word I've
said for two hours in the arguing but
now they're totally curious as to why I
had to stop and pray and what was all
that about and what did you say and how
did you say it and every time I actually
practice my faith I get a million
questions when I want to talk to
somebody about my faith I get a hand
I've heard enough that's good for you
thank you very much or I have this
position and and we start differing so
if I had any advice for myself and
others Dow is so much more powerful and
action than words when it comes to words
instead of going into a chapter verse
understanding I found the most powerful
form of Dawa for all of us as just to
share the concept of tawheed so that
it's clear if we communicate to anybody
on the planet what we believe as
salvation for a Muslim that there's one
God heaven hell day of judgment that
there's a creator who's not like the
creation if you can touch it taste it
feel it it's not God God has these
attributes who we know who God is but we
don't know anything more than that if
you can communicate the perfection of
tawheed the oneness of God and say this
is my salvation if I could if I
challenge that concept and I say
something is God that isn't I'll go to
hell people understand that and you can
leave now at that level because here's
what I found out once somebody
understands Tao heed everybody you talk
to says I believe that they don't true
they do not challenge that but they try
to make their religion fit into it and
that becomes their jiménez let them do
the work out and what will happen is
people will later come back to me I've
given a lecture I've talked I've said hi
I've shared tau eat somewhere I get a
phone call two years later and
somebody's telling me you know what you
said I've been wrestling with it and
today I'm a Muslim or I want to become a
Muslim or I want to cover and it didn't
come from an argument it didn't come
from me talking about their faith and
tell them how to look at their book and
how to see things differently just
here's what I believe I love this
position Salaam alaikum it is powerful
it is it moves mountains and it is the
thing that all of us can share with
anybody we come in contrast minute that
we have tell us you run an organization
called the Muslim legal fund yes tell us
a little about this before we close yes
I'm very excited about an organization
that I helped as a found
it's called the Muslim legal fund of
America it's a charity that opened after
2001 so for the last 11 years it's a
charity that helps Muslims face legal
challenges here in the u.s. we collect
money from Muslims all over the United
States and with the money we collect we
use it to hire attorneys to defend
Muslims in the courtroom and what we've
seen is that this is a very necessary
thing because of the politics of fear
and the things that are going on in this
country
it looks like America is trying to take
a new direction and it's challenging
itself everywhere it's starting to
challenge things and liberties that this
country was founded on freedom of speech
freedom of association freedom of
advocacy freedom of protest freedom to
assemble these things are coming into
question and courtrooms all over the
country and the government is coming up
with theories that this this lawful
conduct fits some kind of criminal
conspiracy and we are very vested in
giving people an opportunity to tell
their side of the story to be
represented so that they're not getting
railroaded in politics of fear and where
these cases can actually be dealt with
in a very fair and professional manner
so I encourage anybody that wants to
learn more about the organization to go
to our website MLF a org I'm gonna put
you on the spot real quickly just
another 30 seconds the person now he's
kind of the same situation here at OU he
told he'd explained this what you had
mentioned what is this concept that we
believe so strongly about that is the
truth real quickly how he it is so
simple it means that there's a Creator
who created everything again if you can
touch it taste it see it smell it if
it's tangible physical in any way it's
not God so we as human beings and the
word Islam needs to submit or to
surrender right to willfully take your
freewill suppress it and say that I want
to follow guidance I want to follow
God's will I want to do what's right
so that willful submission is what the
word Islam means to heed means you're
surrendering to this creator this this
unique being and as a Muslim our
salvation our eternal hereafter depends
on associating nothing that isn't God
with God so for a Muslim our salvation
means if we worship anything
we that's tangible this is a
contradiction to tawheed and that if we
do that we will go to hell so we can't
worship the Sun the Moon the Stars
people planted any idols everything that
that you have in your your your
vocabulary what we could worship other
than God this concept of the Creator is
forbidden and it is so simple and so
pure that it means that you have this
connection with your Creator through the
attributes of God and and all of the
things that God has shared with us about
what God is but that we don't need to
confuse ourselves with any type of
association with God that isn't so how
he does worship the creator and nothing
else that's right thank you very much
and may the creator of the heavens and
the earth same God that Jesus worship
Muhammad Moses and all the messengers
God rewards you thank you very much for
being with us thank you and that's the
message that we're trying to deliver to
you to have a loving relationship with
the one who created creation to worship
the Creator not his creation and you
know what it's a message that resonates
with the heart and if you're a Muslim
put off talking about halal meat for a
minute even talking to your neighbor
about halal meat talk to him about toe
he'd let him get connected with the one
who created creation and put all these
secondary things on hold for a minute
and connect him with the one who gave
him life will give him death and that's
a reality we're all going to die
so let's prepare for that day of
judgment before we say bye-bye and we're
saying bye right here on a Deen show
until next time peace be with you
this is the video this is the danger
so now Michael